good morning of the rules
committee for Thursday August
fifteenth zero point called
order please be advised that
audio video recordings today's
proceedings being missiles
being televised a man secretary
please call the roll Cooley
Cunningham Carillo flora
Grayson Kamlager-Dove here
Maienschein Mathis quirk Silva
from most Rivas Wicks here
we have to help you move
the second factor of uber Mr
Mathis -- seconded by ms
common above -- transaction
please call the roll Cooley
hi formally I'd Cunningham
Carillo flora Grayson
aye Grayson aye Kamlager-Dove
Kamlager-Dove I am majoring
Maienschein aye Mathis Mathis
I Burke Silva hi quirk Silva I
Ramos side Ramos I Rivas works
works I I want to know
the -- are hard working chief
administrative officer is
indisposed this morning she
would ordinarily be here
but -- we have a consent
business in order and we are
confident thank you very much